hi guys dr. Berg here this video we're gonna talk
about how to diagnose nutritional deficiencies
through your eyes the eyes tell it all okay
so the first thing is yellow the whites of the
eyes become yellow or the skin is yellow that is
jaundice so there's a business type of by-product
from bio called bilirubin that backs up to the
liver into the blood and that's why I turned
yellow and that's because something is obstructing
the flow of the bile duct from this connected to
the gallbladder so that's using a gall bladder
problem so that that tells us that your diet
needs to be changed to keep the flows going
through the bile duct so yellow eyes is liver
or gallbladder okay the next one is bloodshot
eyes now yes this can happen when you drink
alcohol but it's also a vitamin b2 deficiency
okay riboflavin and that usually comes from
consuming too many refined grains breads pasta
cereal crackers biscuits waffles pancakes things
like that so in that case you want to stop eating
those foods okay and eat healthy okay that's a b2
deficiency the next one the little clacking on
the eye and it could happen little like little
chunks of something to the eye or it could be the
eyelid that is cholesterol plaquing it's a genetic
problem usually where the person has very high
levels of cholesterol and they just can't seem
to get rid of it in that case what you have to
do is you have to reduce your cholesterol from
the diet unfortunately and take a lot of lecithin
and choline those are the two B vitamins that help
reduce cholesterol I would also say to consume
niacin that would also help lower cholesterol
just to minimize the damage okay the next one
would be cataracts that's where you have this
plaquing on the eye this opaque whiteness that's
obstructing vision and that's a b1 deficiency now
the way you're going to be but one deficiency is
either consuming too much sugar being a diabetic
or go into mass amounts of stress of course
also eating refined grains as well and b1
will cause this Arak okay next one is the inner
eyelid underneath the eyelid it's all red and
irritated it almost feels like there's sand that
is a blood sugar using a hypoglycemia or a blood
sugar issue in that case I put some video links
down below of how to deal with the blood sugar
issues but that's really easy to fix but a lot of
pre diabetics have this this vision issue and it's
all sensitive and irritated inflamed because
that's what it is last one is a little like
a little pimple or a cyst on the eyelid that's a
stye that's also a blood sugar issue because the
white blood cells and neutrophils instead of going
after the bacteria they like to always eat sugar
first so leave the bacteria there they go after
the sugar and they basically become inactivated
so neutrophils are normally there to help eat up
and clean up all this bacteria well it can't get
rid of that because your sugars are off so people
with size normally always consume too much sugar
or they have blood sugar issues okay so again you
can watch the blood sugar video down below okay
well thank you so much for watching put your
comments below and I'll see in the next video